miles good to see you man
congratulations carlos how's it going i
like that outfit you got on the man i i
appreciate that i like the yellow too
you got to come colorful you know i'm
not wearing what it is because it's zoom
listen you do you i thought i thought i
would do you the favor even if you can't
see it you know
sure
so i was just talking to joe and he said
that
one of the things he really loved about
this role for you specifically is
because normally you like to be in
charge of the scene but in this you had
to kind of like really play it back and
sit back until you know a little bit
later on is that something that was a
challenge for you
i i think it was it was a good
challenge for me and i and i think
speaking
or just kind of echoing what what joe
said it did feel different than any
other script that i had done
um it felt like a different character
and and for me i'm always looking for
something different i think
the worst thing you can do is kind of
become complacent or
you know start repeating yourself so i
was i was excited by the challenge of it
um one of the things that really stood
out to me is the soundtrack of this
movie is phenomenal and it got me
thinking about how music actually
affects your moods a lot are there songs
that you use to kind of help you with a
performance like do you ever think about
a song and go oh this is going to get me
into the space i need to be for this
part
i i have um it's not
i tend to go more through through
memories um you know and kind of
digging into into that and i and i can
also fall in love with imagination
that's something i think that i
i can buy into
a you know a false reality pretty easily
but but absolutely there's there's
certain songs that
every time i hear it you know it would
you know it can make me cry
um i gotta say you know you and chris
hemsworth together
uh that's that's a lot of muscly man
right there in this movie did you did
you you know throw down a photo of
yourself
from maverick one of your you know beach
photos just to show them like hey this
is what you're up against buddy no i
mean even i'm but we do get a fight
scene in this and and maybe my character
gets the better of thor which doesn't
that's not going to happen in a thor
movie so i was appreciative of that
that's not too bad how do you how do you
feel about people making all these
thirst tick tocks about you these days
i mean i think i think my wife's like a
a pretty big part of that so i'm it's
i don't i don't have instagram tick tock
some people have shown me some and i
just think it's i think it's funny man i
i just think it's
i don't know it's i i think it's funny
and my wife seems to be having a good
time with it too
that's awesome now this is the third
film that you and joe have done together
is this like a lifetime partnership you
think
i think i think so yeah he seems to come
along at a good time for me
um you know with with when spider head
came along i
i was really wanting to get back to work
and i was feeling i think we all were
just dealing with covet and everything
and there weren't a lot of movies
getting made so i felt very appreciative
of joe and and he's somebody that
whenever he calls he knows i'll answer
and and i just have a lot of trust in
him which i think is probably the most
important thing when you're going to
work with the director
nice hey congratulations again thank you
so much for the time man appreciate it
thanks carlos thanks man
you